foreign
after months of brutal fighting in the
country's East
Ukraine is preparing for its much
anticipated counter-offensive against
Russia
dear Warriors the main battles are
coming soon
since Ukraine's battle plans are
confidential little is definitively
known about the coming counter-offensive
but military experts agree the stakes
couldn't be higher everyone's been
expecting and waiting for it we don't
know exactly when it's going to happen
we don't know exactly where it's going
to happen they've got to look at this
counter-offensive the way a pool shark
looks at a pool table he's not only
trying to sink the ball but he's also
trying to set his cue ball up for a
subsequent shot here's the situation on
the ground right now and what to expect
on the battlefield
since the War Began in February of 2022
Russia has focused its offensives almost
exclusively on the east of Ukraine in
what's known as the donbass region the
offensive hasn't been particularly
successful they've lost thousands of
troops
they've been using brutal tactics
shelling destroying whole districts
after heavy fighting the city of bakmut
is now under Russian control moscow's
first major Conquest since last summer
Russia now occupies 17 percent of
Ukrainian territory a stretch of land
mass roughly equivalent to the size of
Iceland
but the ukraines are still there so at
the moment what we have is something
like a violent stalemate
so far Ukraine's success
and Russia's comparatively poor
performance on the battlefield has
surprised analysts the Russians expected
the Kiev to fall in a few days they
weren't expecting to fight a war they
are expecting to be Marching In A
Victory Parade Mark kimit is retired U.S
army Brigadier General who served in
Bosnia Kosovo and Iraq
very early on it was clear that the
Russian forces not only did they not
have the tactics their equipment proved
incapable of doing that and candidly the
ukrainians surprised us all with both
their tactical ability and their
equipment as well
we will never submit
to any foreigners or colonizers that's
why we fight
from the beginning of the war Ukrainian
president zielinski made it clear that
his aim is to liberate all Ukrainian
territory including Crimea and parts of
eastern Ukraine that were first occupied
in 2014. that seems an unlikely goal for
the immediate defensive
yeah
because that's uh that's a big ask
That's the Law of Russian troops uh you
know who who are well dug in we do not
have that much artillery but
we do stay strong because we do
have truths on our side
Western weapons have been trickling into
Ukraine since the start of the war more
recently there's been a steady
escalation of deliveries
its own Soviet stocks have been
supplemented by large supplies of
weapons from the west and these are
included
long-range rocket artillery systems
called high Mars
more recently you've had the West has
provided battle tanks hopefully they've
got enough armored vehicles and enough
tanks to make that punch necessary for a
counter-offensive but most important
they're going to need the intelligence
from drones perhaps from satellites to
get a good idea of the weakest point of
the Russian front because naturally
that's where they want to attack ahead
of it's counter-offensive Ukraine has
been carrying out drone attacks
the aim is to weaken the Russians ahead
of the broader ground campaign
the current front line stretches 900
miles from the south of Ukraine all the
way around the East up to the Northeast
that's roughly the equivalent distance
between New Orleans and Chicago
so I don't think anybody at this point
can predict the likely attack routes but
they certainly can predict a number of
attack routes that they would use
General Kimmitt envisions four likely
scenarios that the Ukrainian forces
might attempt to kick off their
counter-offensive well I think the first
Avenue of approach I think the most
obvious counter-attack would be from
Harrison
over towards the Sea of Assaf it would
have a significant tactical value
because it would cut this land bridge
that is so vital to the Russians between
Crimea and to the rear of the Russian
forces not only
for Logistics purposes but to
demonstrate to the world that the
Russians own all that area between
Crimea and luhansk the second likely
attack routes would be from zapparesia
down to birdiansk it has very good roads
that make a counter-offensive uh easier
to operate with wheeled and track
vehicles which will be critical to this
war
I think the third attack route would be
through Donetsk down to marry a pole it
wouldn't have the Tactical value as much
of cutting that land bridge because the
land bridge would remain open between
Crimea and a significant amount of the
Russian forces
but the Strategic Communications value
of retaking maryopole that city where
the ukrainians encountered probably
their biggest defeat I don't think you
can overstate the value of retaking
miriapol and getting into the Russian
mines that they have encountered a
significant defeat
the last option I think that the the
ukrainians would have would be attacking
Deweys from Harve to right in through
luhansk that would have a significant
strategic effect because you now would
be on the borders of Russia and that
would be sending a clear message to the
Russian people that the ukrainians are
able to take back much of the land that
they lost in 2014. despite the
ukrainians impressive Battlefield record
thus far kimet is cautious about making
optimistic predictions
I don't believe that the ukrainians will
be able to achieve a complete routing of
the Russians such that they would
withdraw from both Crimea and the
Ukraine and candidly I don't think
unless there's an absolute collapse of
the Russian forces that that will happen
in the next year my major Milestone is
how deep do they get into Ukrainian
territory I'd like to see them get as
far as the water
they've got to decisively defeat the
Russians for this to be a successful
counter-attack and it's got to be
successful enough that it will continue
to inspire the West to provide material
and equipment for the next
counter-attack and the next
counter-attack after that because this
certainly will not end the war Ukrainian
officials have also been quite Keen to
to play Down the sort of the larger aims
of the offensive they recognize that
it's not the case that they'll suddenly
be able to take back all of Ukraine
entirety just from this offensive they
see this as one offensive the next phase
in the war it's an important offensive
it's a critical offensive but it's a not
not uh not to be all an animal